everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm today we are in round 8 of
the 2015 Norway chess tournament been an
epic tournament so far to the top
players in the world competing against
each other we've seen the champion just
get demolished we've seen other
competitors step up their game so far
two of those players we're gonna be
watching today why it's gonna be played
by a nice giri 20 year old grand master
superstar he's just been doing
phenomenal so far especially for so
young he's gonna be a force to be
reckoned with for many many years to
come
his opponent top love is crushing this
tournament he already has five wins in
the first seven rounds and two ties has
yet to lose if he actually picks up a
win in this game then he's won the
tournament even with one round left his
opponent this year nan in round nine is
gonna be second behind him but still
this will be game over he will have
already clinched there's no way that
Vichy and on will catch him so very
important both in each series he's
trying to climb up the leaderboard get a
top three spot into a blob trying to
just wrap this thing up today so pretty
exciting match for us today we'll go
ahead and start with giri playing pawn
to d4 Knight f6 upon c4 pawn to e6 and
then Knight to f3 some of the earlier
matches we've looked at in this
tournament so far we've kind of seen the
nimzo-indian with Knight to c3 instead
and these terior decides to go for the
knight to f3 pawn to d5 pawn to g3 and
then Bishop down here to b4 sort of that
bogo Indian style where the bishop comes
down here to b4 check but white doesn't
have this night here on c3 which you see
a lot in the nimzo-indian white a lot of
times we'll try to avoid that line which
we see in this particular case and then
we continue from here White has a few
options but really the only option you
ever see is Bishop to d2 there's no real
need to play Knight to c3 since that's
kind of what whites have warded in this
spot it doesn't want to have that double
pawn here on the C file and if you
played Knight here to d2 this just kind
of hampers the development of your dark
square Bishop right here so
not seen very often but Bishop T r2d2
and then till Bluff plays Bishop back
here to e7 this is probably the more
passive option that he has in this
particular case he could just take with
his bishop here on d2 this is probably
more draw which though a lot may be
completely fine with getting a draw here
since he doesn't need that many more
points actually win the tournament
although he wouldn't lock it up with the
tie the worst he could do is the draw
but he could play pretty aggressive you
could play Queen to e7 protecting this
that's going to be fine
it could always play pawn to a5 pre
aggressive move attacking the Queen side
of the board right here knowing that his
opponents probably gonna be castling
over here on the Kings side with the
bishop on here G to fianchetto castle
shortly thereafter so immediately
starting the attack on the king queen
side would be good but decides for the
more passive play of Bishop here to e7
now one thing he does look at is White's
played his bishop here to d2 white if he
wants to have a more active Bishop he's
going to have to move it as well so
White's gonna lose a tad bit of tempo
play there by if he wants to bring it to
Bishop here to g5 if he wants to play
Bishop here to c3 all those is not gonna
be stuck here on d2 for too long Bishop
here to g2 s we talked about fianchetto
castle on the Kings side and then castle
on the Kings side for white black now
plays pawn here to c6 kind of morphing
into a semi slob defense where blacks
really trying to hold on to the central
light squares specifically the d5 square
and then once he's kind of done that
he's going to be looking to push on the
Queen side and gain a Queen's Head
advantage with this pawns protected by
his minor pieces so you Queen here to
see to just developing pieces Knight
here to d7 work over here to d1
centralizing that rook right now a pawn
here to be 6 and then pawn to a5 so
really starting to push forward on the
Queen side Bishop here to c3 as we
talked about White has to get a more
active piece form his Bishop and so he
kind of gave up that tempo move that we
discussed earlier
Bishop here to b7 just another defender
on this central square here on
d5 night here it's a d2 pawn here to c5
so topalov starting to play start out a
little bit passive than now he's really
being pretty aggressive he recognizes
that he has a strong set up right now so
he's gonna try to push forward on the
queenside not here to e5 and we see a
capture here on d4 and the recapture and
then some material comes off the board
and then Queen over here to see and it's
important to note that the pawn can't
take here on c4 because this Bishop is
on g2 and so we could easily take this
bishop here on b7 and wants to make sure
that white can't just take here on d5 so
it brings this Queen over here of both
protecting that the pawn can't take and
also protecting this bishop here on b7
now the works gonna swing over to
support that Queen as well now after the
pawn takes we see the bishop take here
on f6 after the bishop takes the Queen's
gonna come up here and we see an
exchange off the board so both sides
deciding that they're just gonna kind of
exchange down to the later stages of the
middle game going into the in game which
my opinion probably favors Topol of a
lot more just because any point that he
can get whether it's half a point for
its high or full point for a win is
gonna be gravy for him so a nice giri
probably needs to play a little bit
different style my opinion if he wants
to try to get that win trying to move up
the leaderboard after the King takes we
see the Queen come here to a b7 check
and then Queen over here to e4 pretty
interesting for me not to see the Queen
take here on e4 I thought black
definitely was going to exchange right
here but decides to go and bring his
work over here to b8 and he could have
brought his rook here to be aid as well
he didn't have to do that but he decided
to go ahead and get his work over here
from f8 involved into the action another
work up here to c6 pretty aggressive
move but not really threatening too much
Queen over here to d7 now that we're
gonna come back we do see a few of the
same moves and then the Queen's decide
to come off the board right here and
then white decides to get pretty
aggressive with his knight now in this
in game we have the rook and Knight
verse the the roofs and Bishop
usually is going to favor the side with
the knight you can usually cut off what
the bishop can do you can always put
your pawns on the opposite color so in
this video your case put the pawns on
the light squares this night can be very
very problematic especially they can
keep everything on one side of the board
that's going to favor whites so going
into the endgame and this giri
definitely has a small advantage here
with a very centralized Knights and he
does have control of both the C and the
D file where to blob over here his rook
on a and a B file aren't really
controlling anything they're playing
somewhat defensive so small advantage
we'll see kind of how that plays out
going into the endgame like now brings
his bishop back here to e7 Knight to d6
could it anytime tow blob could just
exchange off material decides not to you
wants to kind of go for that win now the
Knights just kind of bounce around
attacking this pawn over here on b6 and
then there's an exchange off the board
just simplify things a little bit more
pawn here to b5 I'm not here to e5 as
you can see it's kind of a pain just to
have to worry about this night because
he can bounce over everywhere so easily
now that appear to d7 attacking the
bishop rook over here to see one after
the exchange right here the Bishop to e7
work over here to c7 and this is where
you want your rook you want it attacking
the seventh rank if you're white if
you're black you want to bring it down
here to the second rank right here so
very aggressive spot from White's can
always bring in his work over here - b7
attacking the pawn if he you know this
rook were to move you always have the
threat of rook here to c8 that's going
to be extremely bad especially with we
have the knight here protecting the
square here on f8 so that would be a
quick checkmate so black has to worry
about that so you can see blacks
definitely playing a defensive game
right here his pieces are not super
active they're just trying to hold on so
the nice giri doesn't have an advantage
going into the later stage of the
endgame paneer - g4 is a pretty creative
move I think from a nice giri he
recognizes that he needs to go ahead and
tack on the King side he has the Queen
side kind of locked up as far as
attacking his opponent can't do much
besides the fend on the queenside so
what better than to go ahead and put
more pressure on the kingside knowing
that his opponent can't defend
everything now pawn here to h5 and
taking now you may say oh that's kind of
weird but I just straight-up gave up
material and he did but it's it's gonna
be fairly easy for him to give that
material back once he gets his King
involved into the action he can bring
his King down here once he takes that
he'll have a central King and that's
going to be fairly easy for him to get a
hold of he could also get his other
pieces if he needs to help as well you
know if the King tries to start marching
up the board as well but pawn appear to
be form giving that material back for a
more active night this night is just
going to be very very troublesome for
black so it's attacking this pawn here
on f7 now after the rook to d5 we see
the knight take up here on f7 and then
the rook can just swing over here to h5
another way for blacks to gobble that
material back pawn here to f4 pushing
forward King to g6 and then this pesky
little knight right here has the outpost
from this pawn here on f4 so using all
the material very very nicely these
ponds and the Knights are just working
so well together
now the knight coming back here to f7
now to e5 again so we have a 2 full
repetition if we were to repeat this one
more time it would be a tie game an HG
re sensing that he has the upper hand
does not want to tie this game so plays
Knight back here to f3 and then Knight
up here to a g5 a little bit better
outpost move for him attacking the King
right here and then he's going to in
just a second take this material here on
e6 this Bishop on d2 can't really do too
much it's just protecting this pawn here
on b4 but there's really no good way for
black to continue to push forward
black's pieces are not working well at
all this Knights being a huge nuisance
right now we're over here to h5 and now
Knight taking on g7 is being protected
by this rook as well here on b7 so white
doing a good job in this end game
playing beautiful tactical chess so
that's always good to see
rook down here to h2 Knight to f5 and
then after Knight to e7 we see it come
here to d5 check and then after King to
e4 there's not much places left for
black to go and so we see a rook here to
b6 and then we're going to see black
decide to go ahead and resign after the
word comes down here to b4 and capture
that pawn so night - or excuse me King
to d6 and then the last name of the game
was King here - d4 so perfect didn't
game I think from a nice giri taupe lob
just he he couldn't get his pieces
working together his Bishop was pretty
much rendered useless trying to protect
a pawn here and there in the end game
and the knight was just all over the
board really allowed him to gain control
of the endgame and squeak out a win here
Soto Bluff really needed some points
instead got zero points a nice giri now
moved up into a tie for third place so
congratulations to him as he goes into
the last round with an opportunity to
get second place unfortunately can't win
this and the last round round nine we're
gonna have to aversive vision on
if to blob wins or he ties he will be
crowned champion edition non wins mushy
and non will go on to win one of those
two will win no one else has the
opportunity to win just as far as how
the the points shape up right now so
that's gonna be the exciting match that
will be the match that we cover in
around nine just so everyone is aware of
that hopefully you guys are enjoying
this tournament a lot of coverage so far
I think we've gone over six or seven
matches so far so things going pretty
well but definitely enjoying this
tournament with such high level chests
and I'll see you guys in the next one
thanks for watching everybody